back in Washington it took house Speaker
Kevin McCarthy 15 separate votes to get
the job and declare Victory when he
picks up the gavel today one of the
first orders of business is a vote on
how he wrangled some of his hard-line
conservative critics Nicole Killian is
on Capitol Hill Nicole good morning not
all Republicans are happy on how this
actually went down
yeah that's right there was a lot of
tension over the past couple of days
Nate but today there could be another
potentially divisive vote as House
Republicans prepare to vote on a rules
package that includes some of the
concessions that speaker McCarthy made
to get the job McCarthy was handed the
gavel early Saturday after winning 216
votes breaking and historic stalemate
that took four days and 15 ballots right
before the final vote Alabama's Mike
Rogers had to be physically restrained
from approaching Florida's Matt Gates
one of several GOP holdouts Rogers
apologized Sunday saying I regret that I
briefly lost my temper went over those
hold out to McCarthy pledged to put more
hard-line conservatives on key panels
adjust spending levels and allow a
single lawmaker to call a vote to oust
the speaker some aren't ruling that out
although speaker McCarthy told me that
he is confident he will serve a full
two-year term some moderates are
considering opposing this rules package
because of some of those concessions so
this could all foreshadow future fights
over other contentious issues like the
debt ceiling and funding for Ukraine
Gail
to be continued for sure thank you
Nicole